fox news alert now live look at the
white house where the president's chief
of staff mark meadows is walking up to a
microphone
as the president test positive for kovid
we had a
great jobs report this morning
unemployment down below 8 percent and
the economy continues to be robust in
its v-shaped recovery and
unfortunately uh that's not what
everybody's focused on this morning
as all of you know the
the president the first lady tested
positive uh
for covet 19. uh they remain in good
spirits uh
uh the president does have mild symptoms
and
as uh as we look to try to
make sure that not only his health and
safety and welfare is good
we continue to look at that for all of
the american people
he he continues to be not only in good
spirits but very energetic
we've we've talked a number of times
this morning i got the uh
five or six things that he had tasked me
to do like i do every single morning
and uh he he
is certainly wanting to make sure that
we stay engaged i think
the other thing that is is critically
important
the the doctors continue to monitor
both his health and the health of the
first lady i
will continue to do that they'll they'll
be glad to provide some
some updates uh later today
as as we look at this but i think the
the the great thing about this president
is
is not only is he staying committed to
to working very hard on behalf of the
american people
his first question to me this morning
was
is how how's the economy doing
how are the stimulus talks going on
capitol hill
a number of us in the core team of
the white house continue to get tested
on a daily basis like we are
like we have been and as we look to that
uh we we're very excited about making
sure
that not only that the health and safety
of the president the first lady is
addressed
but certainly that we we address this
this battle together as a nation
together
and the american people can rest assured
that
we have a president that is
not only on the job will remain on the
job and uh
i'm optimistic that uh he'll have a very
quick and speedy recovery mark how would
you describe his symptoms and
is he taking hydroxychloride well i'm
not going to get into any particular
treatment that he may or may not have he
has mild symptoms
as we we look at that the the doctor
will continue to
provide expertise
in the residence he's he's in the
residence now
and in in true fashion he's probably
critiquing the way that i'm answering
these questions
and i i can tell you that a number of us
will uh be reporting back to him
on on the the task at hand what day
in time would you just clear this up
what day and time did you find out that
hope hicks
had tested positive and did you sit on
it until after the president
went out to his fundraiser in new jersey
actually
as as we look at this i'm not going to
get into the tick tock i can tell you in
terms of hope
hope hicks we discovered that right as
the marine one was taking off yesterday
we actually pulled
pulled some of the people that had been
traveling it in close contact
the reason why it was reported out and
just frankly is that we had already
started the contact tracing just prior
to that
event as you know last night even
in in the early hours of this morning
the minute we got a confirmatory test on
the president
we felt like it was important to get the
news out there at that time and so
uh that's why we sent out the the tweet
uh late uh late uh or actually early
this morning
hopefully more than six feet away and if
if there's any any concern there
from a guidance standpoint we have
protocols in place and we
you know when when when when early on
early on when we first
started to tackle the the covet 19
battle
we actually did two different things in
uh
in the white house a number of
contingencies as we looked at
not only additional testing but but
certainly
mitigating the risk for for social
distances in in private meetings and
and the like but i think it goes to the
broader question is
is even with a lot of the mitigating
factors jim
uh what you what you have is is a virus
that is contagious
that that certainly continues to be
regardless of
whatever protocol we have that
that it has the ability to affect
everybody as you know the president
we keep a pretty wide circle all of you
that have interacted with him know that
and so even with that wide circle around
the president we we find that uh
he's having to deal with this like so
many millions of other
americans and people around the world
have had to do
i i can tell you i i can tell you that
what we're doing is focusing
uh on the therapeutics the vaccines
continuing to do that
and that doesn't change
the officials who were on the flight
with the president on wednesday
including
kushner scovino i think stephen miller
was there are they all quarantining have
they been tested
uh we we've tested all of our core staff
and i can tell you that uh
you know mr mr kushner mr scavino myself
a number of uh of us uh have been tested
and
have come back with with negative
results and
and yet at the same time i fully expect
that as this virus continues to go on
other people in the white house will
certainly
have a positive test result and
we've got the mitigation plan in place
to
make sure that the government not only
continues to
to move forward but the the work of the
american people
uh continues to work for uh move forward
and so
even as uh as recent as is this morning
at a little after eight o'clock
the president was giving me a number of
things to to make sure that i get done
and i'm sure that i will actually
have those uh uh do
outs uh have to be back to him uh later
today i've got i've got
a wrap
i'm not going to ask so i wanted to come
out and give an update to all of you
is so that show the courtesy of giving
an update
we'll have future updates i'll be glad
to do that but any other specifics at
this point